I would like to think of myself as a
brand first which embodies the athlete
which embodies everything else but I'd
like to look at myself as a walking
brand I'm so fortunate to grow up about
five miles from Giants Stadium and to
play in this eating
I love being here I love everything that
New York entails the grid the culture I
think it's perfect for not only myself
but my brand as well
I have to pick more person who give the
guy that I want to emulate kind of my
brand gonna be Derek Jeter I think it's
a guy that's been able to stay in New
York and be in the spotlight and do
things that are that are great people
love him here
I'm always humble I'm always a guy
that'll take hundreds of pictures
somewhere
I'm never the guy to say no almost
almost to a fault
I think having jay-z there as someone
that I think is pick up the phone and
shoot a text message or talk to that's
always good they do a good job of
knowing you knowing the person the kind
of moldings around you thanks mom
boys settle down growing up everything
was Nike it was always you know if you
didn't have a pair of Nikes you weren't
like the cool guy on the block so Nike
was always a part of my culture it was
embedded in me so I think it just
naturally became a part of my brand
they asked me to do that salsa dance
it's cool on me I've created this kind
of ramp for myself to do it but when I'm
walking through the grocery store
someone says can you do the dance for me
I'm like right here right now you want
the dance it was something that was kind
of pre-planned but didn't think he was
gonna go this far